da sind wir schon mittendrin bei ihrer
Partei schauen wir uns einmal diese
Karte an man sieht hier viel schwarz
dann sieht man ein grünen ja grünes
Zentrum und dann sieht man hier noch mal
schwarz und das das ist eher Erfolg kann
man sagen das ist ihr voll werden sie
das geschafft Berlin Mitte erscheinen ja
den Wahlkreis in Berlin Mitte haben wir
tatsächlich gewonnen für die CDU und
durfte ich hier repräsentieren dort die
antreten für meine Partei und es ist
natürlich ein toller ein großer Erfolg
dass wir zwei Innenstadtbezirk also auch
im Wedding kann man arbeitet aber Bezirk
gewonnen und hier unten sozusagen den
hauptstadtbezirk zwischen Brandenburger
Tor Alexanderplatz den haben wir
gewonnen ja ein ein Bezirk der der im
Herz der DDR sozusagen ist und eine
lange Zeit von der Linken und ihren
Nachfolgern gewonnen wurde und das ist
ähm ein schöner Erfolg der aber auch
zeigt insgesamt hat Berlin den wechselt
sie haben das gesehen fast keine fast
keine roten Wahlkreise mehr sein die
meisten sind hier wirklich an Union
gegangen Berlin will den Wechsel und es
ist für uns natürlich ein großer
Vertrauensvorschuss von den Bürgerinnen
und Bürgern dass sie uns zutrauen die
Stadt ein Stück weit wieder ins
Funktionieren zu bringen
sogar die Mehrheit der SPD Wähler
wünscht sich eine CDU geführte Regierung
jetzt dabei und ich denke wir werden in
den nächsten Wochen sondieren mit den
Parteien und dann gemeinsam eine
Regierung bilden können dennoch sie
geben sich jetzt optimistisch könnte es
auch sein dass die alte Koalition
einfach weitermacht also wenn wir hier
jetzt mal konkret sie sagen wir kriegen
den Regierungsauftrag mit wie machen sie
das denn dann mit der SPD oder mit den
Grünen oder ist fast eh schon egal weil
fast schon das gleiche also wir haben ja
wir haben ja beschlossen dass wir mit
beiden Parteien sondieren wollen
das schauen wir mal also wir wollen wir
wollen mit dem regieren mit dem wir
diese Stadt nach vorne bringen können
das gerne in der Verkehrspolitik
vielleicht mit der SPD etwas leichter
gehen das kann aber bei dem Thema haben
Modernisierung der Verwaltung vielleicht
auch mit den Grünen dann spannendes
Projekt werden wir gehen in diese
Gespräche sehr offen herein wir
erreichen die Hand den beiden
platzierten die ja zeitgleich dieses
Ziel gekommen sind wenn man das so will
aber mit deutlichem Abstand hinter uns
liegen
150.000 Berlinerinnen und Berliner haben
uns mehr ihre Stimme gegeben als den
Band das klingt aber auch so ein
bisschen so wir nehmen denen wir kriegen
können wie wollen Sie denen das denn
schmackhaft machen was bieten sie nein
wir nehmen nicht den den wir kriegen
können sondern wir nehmen den mit dem
wir unser Programm in weiten Teilen oder
am besten umsetzen können und mit dem
wir einen gemeinsame Zukunft schaffen
können wir diese Stadt die Probleme
liegen auf der Hand manchmal auch auf
der Straße und die wollen wir angehen
und wer damit den Weg mit uns gehen will
mit dem sind wir bereit da ernsthaft
darüber zu reden wo sehen Sie die großen
Unterschiede zwischen Rot und Grün in
Berlin
zwischen rot und Grünen ja habe ja eben
gesagt also das Thema der
Verkehrspolitik das ist bei dem das ist
bei den Grünen wird das sicherlich eine
ganz großes verhandlungsthema über das
war sprechen müssen auch das Thema der
Innenpolitik ist sicherlich mit der SPD
leichter zu gestalten aber sie sehen das
ja auch die Grünen haben hier viele
Wahlkreise gewonnen das heißt es ist ja
immer eine zeigt eine Verwurzelung in
der Stadtgesellschaft deswegen muss man
das ernst nehmen und auch mit den Grünen
offen reden reden
das ist auch in anderen Bundesländern
ist bereits Regierungen gab die trotzdem
die Wahl vorher nicht gewonnen haben nur
Meerschwein ist dann trotzdem möglich
könnte man auch sagen na ja so ist es
eben auch manchmal
machen halt in dem Fall in Berlin dann
die weiter ja es gibt ja es gibt
natürlich keine Verpflichtung der der
SPD jetzt zu sagen okay wir geben das
sozusagen den Krone an die an die CDU
weiter aber ich finde also zehn Prozent
ist schon eine Ansage und ich finde es
erstmal richtig dass du auch
Sondierungsgespräche geführt werden wir
haben selbst eine Redaktion
verschiedenste Meinungen wie es
weitergehen könnte also ich tippe auf
schwarz rot tatsächlich weil ich glaube
dass die SPD und die CDU doch noch als
sage ich mal Parteien eher der Mitte
nach dem ersten vielleicht zusammen
finden jetzt die Grünen ähm mit der CDU
beispielsweise aber klar es gibt
natürlich auch diese diese Konstellation
also Hendrik Wüsten beispielsweise
ich bin wirklich wirklich sehr gespannt
was da am Ende bei rumkommt wenn ich
eine kleine Anmerkung machen darf ich
fand die nur eine porte sehr sehr schön
also ich kann mich erinnern wie damals
bei Armin Laschet die SPD
ihn als schlechten Wahl Verlierer
bezeichnet hat wegen einem Prozentpunkt
ungefähr Unterschied jetzt gewinnen Sie
mit zehn Prozentpunkte und Frau esken
sagt offiziell so jetzt müssen wir jetzt
erstmal analysieren muss ich sagen was
müssen sie dann noch analysieren also
egal was am Ende bei rumkommt ich weiß
nicht ob es ein klares Signal war das
was ein bisschen starkes Signal und klar
ist ein ganz klassisches weiter so kann
es nicht geben also ich glaube es wäre
schon ein bisschen auch ich glaube der
andere wird sich auch verarscht
vorkommen jetzt quasi die Regierung mit
dem Personal dass sie aktuell hat jetzt
einfach so weiter macht das wäre nichts
gewesen bitte die SPD auch so ein
bisschen ihre Stammwählerschaft aus den
Augen verloren hat man das jetzt in der
Hauptstadt gesehen eine Arbeiter
beispielsweise die SPD die eigentlich
während des hier gerade gesagt na ja ob
wir es mit den Grünen mit der SPD da
gibt's Politik vielleicht ein großer
Punkt aber sonst unterscheidet sich der
teilweise gar nicht mehr so viel gesagt
die SPD ist eigentlich eine Volkspartei
und hat sich einlullen lassen von
irgendeiner walkenes an der Mehrheit
vorbei es wird Politik an der Mehrheit
vorbei gemacht die haben Wahlkampf an
der mehr und sie haben Berlin an der
Mehrheit vorbei regiert und deswegen ist
das was der Schal sagt richtig dass die
Mehrheit hier sich gewünscht hat dass
ein Wechsel stattfindet hier war eine
wahlklatsche und die jetzt einfach zu
ignorieren und so tun als wäre diese
komische Dreierkoalition wiedergewählt
worden ich meine rechnerisch ja ist sie
wieder gewinnen aber als wäre sie
bestätigt worden ist falsch und es wäre
demokratisch legitim da jetzt weiter zu
machen aber wäre es wirklich okay ich
glaube nicht gesagt er hätte für möglich
für wahrscheinlich SPD und CDU zusammen
glaubst du Viktor dass ich damit die SPD
so ein bisschen wieder rehabilitieren
könnte wenn sie jetzt in einer Regierung
in Berlin geht mit der CDU sich dann
auch wieder auf diese Seiten zu besinnen
starke SPD ist glaube ich für dieses
Land und auch für Berlin total wichtig
das muss es geben das muss eine Partei
geben die die Arbeiter sie haben selbst
gesagt
repräsentiert aber das kann nur
passieren wenn sie sich komplett neu
erfindet ich wünsche Ihnen dass Sie mit
denen eine Koalition gehen ich glaube
das kriegen sie nicht hin übrigens ich
glaube es wird ein ähm ja muss ich
leider sagen
ja ich habe zu dritt weiter regieren
leider so schade es ist aber ich wünsche
der SPD auch von Herzen dass Sie sich
neu erfinden kann und personell auch neu
erfinden und wir wissen alle was das
bedeutet ein Ersatz für Franziska
gefallen das müssen wir mal schauen also
wir sind in den nächsten Jahren ist
jedes Jahr in Berlin eine Wahl also
im nächsten Jahr findet die Europawahl
statt im Jahr danach die Bundestagswahl
und im Jahr danach weil das ja eine
Wiederholungswahl war die nächste Berlin
war also wenn rot rot grün hier
tatsächlich in den nächsten drei Jahren
noch mal dieses Experiment sage ich
jetzt mal wagen will diese Experiment
hier Koalition die in den letzten Jahren
schon an vielen Stellen flixschusterei
betrieben hat dann blicke ich dem sehr
entspannt entgegen vielleicht gibt's ja
auch noch geschrieben einen kleinen
Joker Kevin Kühnert Joker der SPD
glaubst du das etwas bringen kann
also der ist ein griffiger Typ ziehen
alle er hat nie so richtig gearbeitet
außer meinem Call Center deswegen haben
glaube ich viele Arbeiter in der SPD so
gewisse Störgeräusche mit ihm aber
besser als Franziska Giffey ist er
allemal ich glaube auch wenn der in
ihrem Wahlkreis angetreten hätte dann
betrug quasi perfekt wenn man jetzt dann
noch Kevin Kühnert
also Wahlbetrug von sowas würde ich
niemals sprechen ist nicht meine
Wortwahl
wer die Mehrheit der Bürgerinnen und
Bürger hinter sich hat keine Regierung
und natürlich geht's darum um die
Mehrheit im Parlament das weiß ich schon
rot rot grün hat da rechnerisch noch
eine Mehrheit aber ich glaube wenn man
jetzt so die Nachfrage fragen Sie auch
anschaut 65 % der Berlinerinnen und
Berliner wünschen sich eine Regierung
Unterführung der CDU auch die Mehrheit
der SPD Wähler erkennt das an und sie
haben es ja richtig gesagt also 10 %
sind eine Hausnummer und das sehen auch
die Leute draußen auf der Straße so ich
empfehle den Kolleginnen und Kollegen
von SPD und Grünen nächstes Wochenende
das zu tun was sie letztes Wochenende
auch getan haben ihren Infostand zu
packen sich in die Fußgängerzone zu
stellen und mit den Menschen darüber zu
reden glaube wenn Sie mehr glauben wenn
sie was sie glauben wer diese Stadt
regieren soll ich glaube sie werden sehr
eindeutige Antwort bekommen
spannend was in der Hauptstadt passiert
wir haben schon angesprochen sie haben
sich ja auf den Weg gemacht nach
Mallorca gehören das Ganze aus der Ferne
beobachten schütteln sie da so ein
bisschen den Kopf was gerade in der
Hauptstadt passiert da kommt erst die
Wiederholung von der Wahl denn wir
erinnern uns da ging dann irgendwelche
Wahlzettel auf verloren auf dem Fahrrad
musste man noch mal neue besorgen jetzt
also die Wiederholung und jetzt sagt
aber die alte Koalition ja moment mal
eigentlich können wir jetzt weitermachen
wie bisher sind sie da fast froh
ausgewandert zu sein und ähm ich habe
gehört dass das was in der Hauptstadt
passiert in der Politik in dass das
sozusagen die das Zukunft die
zukunftsproduktion von dem ist was dann
für den Rest des Landes auch noch
zutrifft und dann muss ich sagen bitte
nicht ja also bitte machen Sie
anständige Politik ja
mehr kann ich dazu nicht sagen also
immerhin haben sie es jetzt geschafft
offenbar die zweite Wahl ordentlich zu
organisieren das ist auch schon was 450
oder die Hammer gefunden wurden halt
nicht ganz also gibt's nur ein paar
kleine Haken aber jetzt mal ernsthaft
gab es für sie bestimmte Gründe
auszuwandern in Deutschland zu verlassen
immer wieder sind wir auch hier in
dieser Sendung und kritisieren viele
Punkte schauen den Politikern da auch
ganz genau auf die Finger gab es bei
ihnen irgendeinen bestimmten Grund wo
sie sagt nee also ich muss jetzt
wirklich woanders leben ja es gab
mehrere Gründe also der persönliche ist
natürlich auch ich habe ja Dolmetscher
studiert und wissen Sie wenn Sie eine
Weile im Ausland waren und dann kommen
sie wieder zurück nach Deutschland und
dann sehen Sie immer wieder dieselben
also ich meine das ist ja hier eine
ziemlich deutsche Runde ja es sind
werden wir reden über walkners und und
über Hundekacke Attacke also das sind so
Täter sind so typisch deutsche Themen ja
die Deutschen sind die Deutschen sind
Weltmeister im aufregen ja und wissen
Sie warum es keine WM im in empörungs WM
gibt weil die Deutschen immer die
Weltmeister werden also und das ist eben
so ein Ding da wünscht man sich dann
eben auch mal woanders hin und abgesehen
davon ist das Wetter in Friede und
Sonnenschein aber ich glaube in Spanien
in den talkshop da schreibt man sich
doch an ohne Ende oder da ist ja nicht
so dass er Frieden und Freude ja das ja
das stimmt aber das gehört auch
irgendwie zum Temperament und die sind
danach ganz fröhlich wieder also ja
zimmertemperament bei uns ist geweckt
sind
[Gelächter]
nach Spanien auswandern um ein bisschen
verwirrt teilweise auf diese Hauptstadt
zu gucken also ich bin ja kein Berliner
ich bin ja Münchner und muss reicht auch
vier Stunden sich im ICE zu setzen damit
zu fahren von München mal zu beobachten
was in Berlin so abgeht um sich schon
auch durchaus zu wundern also auch die
verbunden gibt es auch Ernährung
Umgebung trotzdem ich bin auch
Dolmetscher und Patricia weiß dass ich
habe hier für Bild auch schon sehr viel
dolmetscht den ganzen Prozess am Behörde
Johnny Depp und so und ich kenne das
alles ich habe auch mal in Spanien
gewohnt in Katalonien so wie sie aber
ich bin trotzdem immer noch sehr gerne
in Deutschland